CNN has leaked audio of Donald Trump
confessing to his crown yeah not really
it's uh it's kind of nonsense audio and
a lot of people are like this is the big
breaking story about Trump the the audio
proves doesn't prove anything but we are
going to talk about that however we're
not leading with that story and I'm
going to tell you why
and it matters because for eight years
the media has lied about the context of
every single Story related to Donald
Trump and so when they come out CNN
publishes audio and they say this audio
proves something the rule is you're
supposed to wait three days because that
invariably something else comes out goes
actually that was fake and that seems to
be the way it goes so we'll definitely
talk about the the audio uh leaks of
Donald Trump's conversation pretend to
classify documents but we do have more
pressing and important news surrounding
censorship the culture war and a bunch
of other topics